voilà l'arrivée du corps du cc nogent
revient d'un saut ville qui était en vue
de la deuxième classe pour les vidéos
donc avec l'autre pour les senneurs
l'écart est de 19 secondes
c'est une cause d'attentes j'avais que
le circuit est assez usant je voulais
pas me dévoiler trop tôt a pas laissé de
cartouches
j'avais pas cool non plus au quesne
dernier donc je savais pas trop si sur
la fin de course jal atteignant j'ai
fini un peu sur les campements
heureusement il ya une petite chute au
dernier virage et j'ai crampes et juste
au moment de la chute du coup après pour
relancer c'était un peu il ya eu des
vagues et j'ai perdu un peu des places
mais bon s'ils passent assez
satisfaisante aux championnats de france
élite et je fais un peu honneur à la
martinique et j'espère que de plus en
plus sur des coureurs élites qui
viendront champion de france un peu
mouillé le maillot et ce sera une bonne
chose pour le cinéma